this is the fall of shooters and one of
the bigger ones coming out this year is
titanfall - I'm Justin hey old and I'm
talking with Rob handler II who spent an
extensive amount of time with the game
now titanfall 1 did not really have much
of a single-player component it was
primarily a multiplayer shooter and he
had to glean what was going on from the
world around it but there changing that
up in titanfall 2 there's a whole
single-player campaign and you played
through the entire thing I did yeah so
so what do you think about it just in
general what's your impression uh in
general first impressions or it's a very
solid jam-packed campaign however I
would say I really wanted a little more
in the end in that my playthrough time
was about five hours on regular
difficulty I will say that that five
hours there was a lot going on like it
seemed every corner there was a really
well polished good looking game there
are other parts down the road of the
campaign that I felt were kind of
lacking but yeah I had a great time with
it well thinking about the lobe length
especially for Call of Duty and
Battlefield those are typically pretty
short experiences do you feel like it
compares to that as far as what you've
got out of that experience it's very
different and that's a bigger discussion
right like what where does your time
factor in like most people you know RPG
want those 100 hours whatever plus I
think of a shooter campaign as being you
know upwards maybe to ten hours and I
think that is or can be an issue however
the five hours that I played were really
exciting and I was never at any point
frustrated or bored I think it was just
very smartly done it was very like well
orchestrated it was again like
jam-packed is how I would imagine it
like even looking back at the footage I
captured like it was like wow this is a
really great looking game see you down
there rifleman
good luck get your ass out of the simpad
Cooper eat at the dropship but yeah just
to kind of also go over like what this
single player is about is you know this
time around it's very heavy very heavily
played into the fact that you are a
person and you have a bond with this
Vanguard class Titan who was kind of
like a one of a kind and he's got a very
how would you say kind of stubborn
personality after Captain la Somoza is
killed in combat he gives you the Titan
you are just a simple good-for-nothing
bum of the barrel rifleman and you kind
of rise to become the hero of the game
so in this game only specific people
have Titans and that's kind of like
rising up in the ranks to being a
top-tier commando right and as you do
that the game does a very smart way and
it's I think people would compare it to
like Mega Man esque type situations
where after you beat a boss you get a
new class more or less of Titan so
Scorch is one the first ones you get you
become scorch you now can switch as the
game progresses you can switch between
loadouts which is really fun and it
really changes up the pace because as
you know this time around the Titans are
taking a very character-based
stance and that's well expressed at the
game kind of unfolds well that's really
interesting that especially when you
think about this compared to other
shooters battlefield Call of Duty those
are typically very narrative focused but
it sounds like this is more of a
traditional experience if you have boss
battles against the Titans that you're
gonna unlock mm-hmm so is that how it
plays out then absolutely fighting
against this then you unlock him yeah it
does that at times though it's actually
not so much as you kill the boss and you
get his weapon the next level occurs and
you just kind of pick up the weapon on
it on the ground and then eventually a
couple of these weapons are just kind of
handed to you so that kind of loses its
like punch I think at times but the
levels are very structured around that
like each you can definitely count on a
boss being at like every end of the
level I've also heard a lot of
comparisons in the single-player to
games like portal 2 both in maybe the
humor and in the the puzzle solving
absolutely and there are essentially
three ways this game kind of handles
what your experience is and that there
is pilot combat your general general neo
first-person shooter experience titan
combat and then pilot platforming so
many levels do a fantastic job at taking
the platforming that you know from the
game but also adding a mechanic or a
changeup that will prohibit you from
traveling through a level for instance
certain moments you're on foot you're
unable to traverse around because of
some nasty fog in which case you need
again you're tight in order to go
through or you have to hit a switch
forcing you out of the Titan traversal
round a lot of puzzles in this game and
those are played pretty well like I had
a fun time doing so and I will say that
there are two levels in this game that
are original so original that I was
awestruck by like how they were done and
is killing me that I can't talk about
them especially round around the office
here but they are so original and fun
that I would go back and play them
multiple times again yeah of course we
don't want to talk about spoilers at all
right people watching this probably
haven't even gotten a chance to play yet
but what is it that you think makes
those things exciting and fun I don't
want to spoil it it's like it's just a
changeup and that's what the game is
really doing is that you are given
platforming and I would say at times
again like these two levels are very
standout ish and then later on it's kind
of just I would say almost more of a
gimmick like something I've seen before
and that's fine and it makes things
difficult you know I have to operate
cranes in order to basically make a my
own platforming path but there are so
there are these two other things that
happen in the game that I think for me
at least kind of like changed a synapse
in my head and made me realize how I can
utilize this idea this mechanic that is
changing up the platforming and the game
does a really great job at that again in
these in certain moments and then I
think a lot often times it's simple and
it's it's not necessarily difficult
however I would say that if they were to
like a like for the crane system for
instance that almost got a little
tedious however if it if they if they
went more puzzle esque and made me
really think about oh I need you know I
I have to do multiple things at once I
think that would perhaps detract from
the actual shooter experience again and
I will mention this praying level what I
think I needed to have done was play
this on a higher difficulty because I
kind of flew through some of these and I
would recommend anyone play to set a
higher difficulty because I think
certain levels the platforming and how
you utilize it is all about titanfall
and I think there are moments where like
you Dai is so difficult or can be so
difficult that you need to basically
find ways of platforming around to
better help you and in your quest to
kill this titanfall to gonna answer some
of those questions about what is this
world and what is the setting for where
this game takes place I would say yes no
you're never really given answers to
like the world itself just more or less
your mission so you be almost the entire
time the only knowledge that you are
given because you can hear you're a
nobody rifleman the only knowledge you
were given is through your companion bTW
and that's the Studer and again there
are like pretty funny dialogue choices
one being a more humorous response to
bTW or like a kind of more sincere one
and those are kind of nice to go through
humans concept of love requires
admiration attraction devotion and
respect conclusion I am 50 percent in
love but again it's it's a very cut and
dry just like you're on a mission but I
would say as far as if you're looking to
know like everything about this world
you're just kind of doing it through the
eyes of this robot further dinosaurs yes
there are there are there are like not
many I would say that much good I just
want all games to be dress apart yeah
your biggest criticism with game what
would that be one of my biggest
criticisms I'd have to say is for a game
that is really great and think speaking
of the multiplayer with abilities right
you get the new grapple you get cloak
and get all these abilities the game
does not really handle the pilot
abilities that well yes you get
different you know load outs for your
Titan as the game progresses you're
really only introduced or given one and
I think that was kind of a bummer
because there is something to say about
time Paul I changing it up like again
like the grapple changed the platforming
game it would have been nice to have
been given that and then taken that away
or like you know like having a diversity
in pilot abilities would have been a
much more creative experience but I
would say to pull that back is it is a
task or just a single-player narrative
and it's very much that and I think if I
want that those pilot abilities that's
why there's multiplayer and I can look
forward to playing that again like you
know there are just there are moments
where wall running and platforming can
get a little simplified despite their
attempts of like adding curveballs you
know like wall fires in your face now
how you can how you gonna platform
around this those can get a little
boring but in general I think it's just
like a short and sweet campaign I would
have liked more I think that's where I
was a little bummed was I would have
liked more so ultimately do you feel
like this adds to the experience or do
you feel like you know you really just
want a multiplayer and it would have
been fine without a single-player game I
think it adds to the world but that's
what people want it so I think in
general if it played it safe and it
delivers in that respect that you're
getting like an answer to like why is
why is there a battle between the
militia and the IMC there's reasons
behind it and there's now there's even
more of a stance like what's funny
enough is I feel like in the first game
you kind of had an idea that the militia
with good guys and IMC we're bad guys in
this game it's full on IMC they're
messed up there like vault-tec messed up
which is pretty interesting so it's
almost like this is the game that should
have been in the first one it's like
they just wipe the plate clean and
they're like now establishing the story
of
titanfall I think they have achieved
that well people will get to try it out
soon when does the game come out the
28th so in October October super soon so
October 28th titanfall 2 is gonna be out
in stores and if you want to read our
full review and get more tips and tricks
about how to play the game stay tuned to
game spot calm went three knots heading
to 74 range 95 meters projectile mass 89
kilograms
trust me
I think I'm going to need some new
Underpants copy that